I want to talk about alternative solutions
to taking pills
for the rest of your life
If you struggle with speaking anxiety
at all, you've probably encountered
beta blockers such as prepare
all these pills
you take that, reduce your heart rate,
reduce your blood pressure,
reduce the bodily symptoms you experience.
A lot of people are looking to that
as a solution to their speaking anxiety.
I'm trusting the Montebello
I was one of the fastest competitors
to reach the final of the World
Championships of Public Speaking
and that journey
completely changed my life.
It changed my confidence.
It changed how
I walked around in the world.
And it led me to co-found a company,
ultra speaking.com, with Michael Gendler,
where we've devoted our lives
to figuring out how to solve public
speaking anxiety once and for all.
So let me start by saying that
I have nothing particularly strong
against prepared at all.
I don't really like the idea of taking
pills for the rest of my life in anything,
but I know plenty of students who take
for panel all have taken prepared a lot.
But I know many, many more. Who.
Have gotten off of these pills
and no longer
imagine a world
where they'd ever need them
because of the journey they've been
on, tackling their speaking anxiety.
The way I see a lot,
I see it as a life jacket
you're thrown in the middle of the ocean
and you don't know how to swim, a life
jacket will save your life.
But the reality is,
if you are completely dependent
on this life jacket
and you live in water world, then it's
probably a good idea to learn how to swim,
In my mind, communication is ubiquitous.
It's everywhere in your life,
particularly the type of communication
that you can't prepare for.
So what can you do to reduce your anxiety?
The three things I want to state
number one is
you want to change the state
in which your body is.
When you find yourself in a situation
where you know you're going to speak.
if you have anxiety,
you're experiencing a lot in your body.
Your body is going to be on high alert.
So before going to work, before
a social situation, before a presentation,
go out for a long run, go out for a bike
ride, a swim or a workout.
Do anything
that's going to release endorphins
and allow your body
to have a lower baseline.
Second piece of advice is take a breath
before you speak.
It sounds so simple, but if you just
take one breath in and a long breath out.
Which looks completely natural,
you're going to lower your baseline,
which is going to lower the peak
of anxiety, which is going to make
you feel that much more comfortable.
And last but not least,
maybe the most important piece of advice
I can give you is join some kind of a club
that's going to create a safe environment
for you to practice your skills.
You can join a bowling club,
a gardening club, a professional club.
It doesn't matter.
You can even join an ultra speaking club
which is specialized in speaking anxiety.
But The only thing that matters
is that you find yourself in a situation,
in a scenario where you're going to be
with the same people week after week.
Here's what's going to happen.
You're going to get comfortable
with these people.
You're they're all going to be rooting for
you as a human being.
And as a result, you're going to be able
to take more and more risks
to show yourself more and more.
And as you do so, in an environment
that's very safe,
where you're going to be rewarded
for taking risks,
your body is going to learn
that it's actually safe in doing so,
and you're going to have a playground
where you can spend time
finding yourself
and finding your own voice
what you're doing is you're building
a stack of evidence
that builds up your confidence
and is going to allow you to
then go into different environments
knowing what it feels like to be you,
what it feels like
to be a confident version of you.
Look, there's no shame
in taking medication for real problems.
But for the vast majority of people,
there's a world in which you can take
the life jacket off and learn how to swim.
I know this can be very scary.
It's a big journey,
and it's a very personal journey.
It will be very unique to you,
but it's going to be
very energizing
and rewarding as you're on the journey.
And I think that's what's magnificent
about these personal growth ventures
that we get on as we take the first step,
we get energy from that very thing.
So this is a truly worthwhile journey,
and I wish you
good luck.
You like. Do.
You. Yeah.